la politique extérieure élément
incontournable de la campagne
présidentielle
illustration avec une nouvelle salve de
sanctions contre téhéran a annoncé cette
nuit par le secrétaire d'état mike p o
le secteur financier iranien sur liste
noire avec dix huit principales banques
visées pour je cite stopper l accès
illicites au dollar américain
des mesures punitives censée entrer en
vigueur dans 45 jours soit après
l'élection présidentielle américaine
et on en parle avec thierry coville
spécialiste de l'iran et chercheur à
l'iris institut des relations
internationales et stratégiques
bonjour thierry coville merci d'accepter
notre invitation
selon la sémantique de mike pompéo cette
nuit je cite à la compagne de pression
économique maximal va se poursuivre tant
que l'iran n'acceptera pas de conclure
une négociation globale qui s'attaque
aux comportements néfastes du régime qui
a l'accord veut l'administration trend
alors oui vous êtes bonne question en
fait ce qu'ils voudraient c'est que
l'iran accepte de se faire des grandes
négociations que les états unis de
renégocier l'accord sur le nucléaire que
les états unis ont quitté en mai
2010huit de négocier a également un
nouvel accord sur la présence iranienne
dans la région
est ce que les états unis pensent qu'ils
sont des stabilisateurs également de
négocier un arrêt ou une diminution du
du programme balistique iranien tirer
coville le secteur financier visées par
ces sanctions mais on sait qu'il ya eu
le le pétrole et et bien d'autres
domaines qui ont subi des sanctions du
côté de liron que va changer cette
nouvelle salve concrètement pour le
peuple iranien
je pense pas grand chose d'ailleurs vous
l'avez dit les sanctions commenceront à
être appliquée après les 45 jours donc
après les élections américaines
c'est vrai que l'iran si vous levez
l'objectif des états unis c'est de
mettre une telle pression sur l'iran aux
pressions économiques maximale je pense
y ait peu de pays qui ont été autant
sanctionnés donc vous l'avez dit les
rendre exporte quasiment plus de pétrole
l'or le pétrole c'est 80 % des recettes
en devises de l'iran est également avec
beaucoup de sanctions sur les bancs 1
les flux financiers entre l'iran et le
reste du monde sont très très compliqué
avec toutes ces sanctions qui a eu il ya
quasiment très peu de banques qui osent
commercer avec l'iran parce qu'elles ont
toujours peur d'être sanctionné donc
voilà l'idée des états unis je pense que
l'idée suppose qu'il ya beaucoup de
stratégies électorales guide et je pense
cette stratégie ne marche pas parce que
c'est des faits l'iran a refusé de
négocier pour l'instant il attend les
prochaines élections américaines
mais je pense que donald trump veut
montrer voilà il continue sa stratégie
qui d'un côté il ya un message on va
dire même parce que l'umih subliminal
adressé aux iraniens ne croyez pas que
vous allez vous retrouver joe biden
c'est possible que vous ayez à discuter
avec moi à de dire dans quelques mois
voilà la semaine dernière 26 pays dont
la chine la russie et l'iran justement
on fait une déclaration commune à l'onu
par ap washington et certaines capitales
occidentales à cesser ces sanctions pour
agir ensemble face au corona virus
cet appel n'a pas été pris en compte par
la maison dont je visiblement oui oui
c'est très intéressant de rappeler ça
parce qu'il faut se rappeler qu'on est
là et les cris du coronavirus les
iraniens mais aussi des européens les
chinois les russes et même des
personnalités américaines comme bernie
sanders ont dit jeudi ses sanctions
envers gaz qu'il faut bien voir et
privent quand même le gouvernement
iranien ça c'est des faits rares jeudi
de long va dire le tiers de ses recettes
budgétaires
un pays dont on prive le 30% de ses
recettes budgétaires pense à la france
comment ce pays fait pour lutter contre
que le voir à la virus parce que l'iran
a besoin d'équipements voilà de
personnel médical d'équipement de de
matériel médical pour lutter concept que
cette crise à l'iran est le deuxième
pays dans la région asie moyen-orient
après l'inde en termes de décès avoir
été touchées par cette crise et donc les
l'iran a demandé à près de 5 milliards
de dollars au fmi les etats unis ont dit
qu'ils s'y opposeraient
donc là sous la conclusion de cette
action américaine c'est que non non
seulement on les accepte même pas de
desserrer l'étreinte pour permettre à
l'iran de lutter contre le court-noué un
virus il en faut encore plus donc
effectivement vous avez raison il
n'écoute même pas la communauté
internationale et à limite c'est une
nouvelle fois aussi un défi à la
communauté internationale
moi j'espère quand même d'ailleurs une
réaction comment accepter qu'un pays via
les rangs en termes de morts par jour a
même dépassé le pic qu'ils avaient
atteint lors de la
un vague de la crise donc je veux dire
le sanctionner encore plus un pays qui
est déjà très affaibli et qui subit
comme ça de plein fouet la crise du
courant la virus
bon on va dire voilà donc moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que c'est un défi à la
communauté internationale
justement vous parlez de la communauté
internationale thierry coville qui elle
peut être les mots de la communauté
internationale après cette annonce de
mike pompéo on sait que le jcp aux
halles fameux accords de vienne a été
déchiré en mai 2018 par donald trump
on sait que dans ce cet accord de vienne
il y à la russie il n'ya l'europe la
france la grande-bretagne notamment qui
est la russie qui appellent aux états
unis à revenir autour de la table
justement ces pays là qu'est ce qu'ils
peuvent dire après cette annonce de my
pomper ou à quoi est ce que vous
attendez de la par la communauté
internationale alors il ya une première
chose moi je suis ici je parle des
européens jugent que je connais un peu
mieux ce que font les européens
c'est très clairement tout le monde
attend les élections américaines ciblé
cette mesure arrive dans un contexte
particulier je pense que les diplomaties
européennes très clairement l attente
des élections américaines est entre
guillemets espère une élection de joe
biden parce que c'est assez clair de
faim csg obaida la digue de toute façon
ils reviendraient dans l'accord donc
supporter les diplomaties européennes
experts que joe biden reviendra dans
l'accord et donc les a priori les
sanctions contre le pétrole iranien
serait levé ce qui permettrait à l'iran
de respirer et je pense que joe biden
peut-être prendre eux aussi des mesures
pour permettre à l'iran d'avoir un accès
plus facile au matériel médical et aux
médicaments
mais d'un autre côté je pense que il me
semble que du côté européen
premièrement ce serait quand même bon de
répéter même si on attend les prochaines
élections américaines que ce que fait
les états unis sur le plan du droit
international
c'est quand même inacceptable ils ont
quitté cet accord quasiment sans raisons
légales et je viens d'en parler
étudiants resserrer l'étreinte
économiques contre l'iran au moment où
ce pays doit faire face à une vague
encore plus élevé de décès liés aux
coronavirus je pense il ya un côté voilà
comment dire contre contre le droit
humanitaire quand
droit international et j'espère que
l'europe va pas simplement attendre les
élections américaines j'espère que
racontent des déclarations également je
pense que même si tu oses hayden est élu
je pense qu'il faut pas oublier tout ce
qui s'est passé je pense que l'europe a
un vrai problème de crédibilité
c'est vrai que il ya que les états unis
ou qu'ils étaient d'accord mais entre
nous mais on sait très bien les
européens à part des déclarations in ce
texte le mécanisme de troc a été créée
par zoug berne n'a fait qu'une seule
transaction de 500 mille dollars de
matériel médical et c'est même palier je
crois à la lutte contre le courant n'a
virus donc on peut pas dire que les
européens étaient très actifs sur ce
dossier donc j'espère que même si tu as
bayonne est élu la leçon au reste et
pour la crédibilité de la politique
européenne par rapport à cet accord même
même en général je pense que ce serait
bien que les européens fassent preuve
d'un peu plus de volonté politique pour
s'affirmer
excusez-moi facile face aux états unis
merci thierry coville d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur à l'iris et spécialiste de
l'iran